and welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with breaking news on the withdrawal of
all US military forces from northern
Syria there is growing chaos in the
region after President Trump's decision
to pull back US troops in the face of a
Turkish military onslaught for the first
time in years forces loyal to the Syrian
regime are occupying key cities formerly
held by us back Kurdish forces the
spiraling violence has also allowed
hundreds of Isis supporters to escape
captivity the US had about a thousand
troops in northeastern Syria fighting
Isis alongside those Kurdish allies of
the United States Charlie d'Agata has
been on the ground in Syria and just
crossed into neighboring Iraq well aside
from US troops were among a handful of
people who got the heads-up that the
withdrawal was about to be announced it
was like a two-minute warning we had to
pack up and get moving because the
situation on the ground was about to
change dramatically and quickly
America's allies hear that Kurdish
forces were taking a pummeling Turkish
troops advancing more quickly than
anyone had expected on the ground
Turkish back Syrian militias they even
filmed themselves executing Kurdish
soldiers and civilians on the roadside
dozens of civilians have been killed
more than a hundred thirty thousand
people displaced this is what this place
looked like until last week this whole
area under control of us back Kurdish
forces the Turks and their militias
drove all the way to a crucial highway
choking off supply and escape routes
now the Syrian regime is pushing forward
swallowing up the key cities of kobani
Qamishli and al-hasakah we were in
hosaka when the news broke about the
u.s. pull out we not only had to avoid
Syrian regime forces Turkish artillery
and air strikes their militias but also
Isis cells exploiting the newly created
power vacuum the militants had already
detonated car bombs in Qamishli and
hosaka from where we were based to the
direction we were heading
hundreds of Isis family members and
supporters had escaped from a detention
camp Kurdish forces were struggling to
contain 11,000 Isis detainees and dozens
of high-value prisoners were never
handed over to US forces despite
president Trump's assurances this
relatively peaceful part of Syria has
now descended into chaos and violence
now we've just crossed over into Iraq
from Syria because there are rumors that
the Syrian regime was about to take over
and close that checkpoint just gives you
an idea of how quickly the situation on
the ground has changed and how hostile
that environment was that prompted the
withdrawal of US forces Charlie d'Agata
reporting there thanks charlie